well get ready for the next generation
of wwe superstars today wwe held talent
tryouts at mgm grand for both the men
and women
their ultimate goal to be selected to
train at the wwe performance center in
orlando 40 candidates tried their luck
today including las vegas born
california raised faith jeffries guess
what got a contract
i
feel so blessed right now triple h just
looked me straight in the eyes and said
we want to offer you a contract and
moving to orlando within the next 30
days
yeah this is freaking cool so i'm at a
loss for words i literally broke down
crying and i don't like to cry in front
of anyone and here i am crying in front
of everyone over there so yes i'm
extremely grateful right now
that's great good for her jeffreys is
only 22. she says she grew up doing
martial arts as a kid eventually got a
black belt in taekwondo when she was
eight progressed with boxing from there
and she turned her passion for wrestling
into a career right out of high school
with women of wrestling there she is
her stage name
think the lioness and as you heard it
she's moving to florida to pursue her
career even further